Yeah.
Okay.
So here's some other ideas that,
okay,
so here's an argument.
I don't know what you think about this,
but I've,
I've often thought about it as an
argument by necessity for evolution.
It's like if the,
if the environment as such is too
complex to predict,
then how do you build anything that can
live in it because living in the
environment is the same as predicting
it.
It's the same problem.
Well let's think about that for a
minute.
The first answer is it doesn't work very
well because you guys have been last
boat 80 years and that'll be that.
So in so far as you are a solution to
the problem of the environment,
you're a pretty temporary one and that's
pretty much the best that our path and
evolution could cobble together in 3
billion years.
So that just shows you how complex the
problem is.
The other issue is that maybe there is
no other mechanism then the Darwinian
mechanism to account for any success
whatsoever.
Because the basic idea is,
well you cobble something together and
is it good enough for the environment?
And the answer to that is probably not.
So you make a million variants and all
the ones that aren't any good die,
and so it's,
it's evolution by an excess of death.
Fundamentally it's you solved the
problem by failing brutally generation
after generation and you know,
I can't see how the problem could be
solved in any other way.
If the answer to the question is the
environment predictable?
No,
because then failure is there's no
alternative to failure the best you can
ever get as temporary success.
So anyways,
you can chew on that.
It's kind of a,
it seems to me to be correct.
Now a couple other things here as you
have to accept some propositions for
this argument to go forward and actually
laying out the propositions is the hard
part.
So one of the propositions I offered you
is that you look at the world through a
frame of reference.
In that frame of reference is both
cybernetic and narrative.
Now you can debate both of those.
You could debate about whether or not
the frame of references,
cybernetic.
All I can tell you about that is when
I've gone through the animal
neuroscience literature,
the people who I thought were most
informed,
broadly informed about psychology and
general psychopharmacology,
neuroanatomy,
functional neuroanatomy,
um,
the really hard end of,
of the biological sciences that are
relevant to psychology,
their models are cybernetic.
So that's kind of interesting.
And then the next interesting thing is
the cybernetic models were designed by
people who were,
who were the founders of artificial
intelligence.
So there's an interesting parallel
there.
And then a lot of the great personality
theories are cybernetic.
You know,
Piaget's theory is basically a
cybernetic theory.
And so perhaps the cybernetic theories
are not exactly right.
That's fine.
But they're pretty damn good.
So I'm going to rest on that for the
time being.
And then the next question is,
well,
is it reasonable to propose that the
fundamental cybernetic frame,
his narrative,
and I would say pretty much none of the
theorizes except for maybe piaget who
have a cybernetic model,
have drawn a relationship between
narrative and cybernetic models.
But here's why.
I think if you look at someone like
Jeffrey Gray who was credibly
intelligent,
well educated psychologist really are
outstanding scholar in my estimation,
he derived his cybernetic models from
Russian cybernetic models that were
based on the presupposition that what
you do when you move in the world is you
compare the current state of the world
to the state you expect.
Okay.
And that's wrong.
It's wrong in an important way because
you're not an expectancy machine.
You're not a cold cognitive computation
machine.
You don't act in the world in accordance
with what you expect.
You Act in the world in accordance with
what you want.
And that's like,
it's a critical difference.
So if you read graze,
for example,
the neuropsychology of anxiety,
and you get a sense of the cybernetic
model that's underneath there,
there's never any real mention of
motivation per se,
except for emotional motivation.
There's the approach system and the the
fear system and the negative emotion
system,
but,
but motivation as such doesn't seem to
enter into it.
You know,
the fact that entities,
animals are hungry and thirsty and
desirous of sexual contact and playful
and all those sorts of things.
You can read Jaak Panksepp for better
descriptions of those systems.
But those things have to be brought
together.
And my proposition as soon as you bring,
bring them together is you get narrative
because you're talking about people who
are motivated and want things and then
descriptions of the structures that they
use to operate in the world to get the
things that they want.
That's a narrative now.
So you can think about that.
That's how it looks to me.
So here's another set of propositions.
The propositions are this and that is
that the systems that we use to perceive
and categorize,
the world did evolve and they evolved in
a manner that's standard with regards to
how things evolve,
which is that new things are built on
old things.
And you can't escape from the old
things.
You have to have them.
They're present in your current model.
So you can't get somewhere from nowhere.
And so you're constrained by your
starting points.
And so I would like to offer you the
proposition that the basic sub elements
of our conceptual structures and
therefore of our narrative structures
are symbolic representations of the
world as a place to act that are based
in our long prehistory of fundamentally
social existence.
And so I'm just going to give you a
brief introduction into some of those
categories.
And so,
and I think that the more probable,
the more long lasting a phenomena is,
the more it's probable that a biological
entity in contact with that phenomena is
going to have adapted to it perceptually
behaviorally and conceptually.
So one of the things we might think
about is given your nervous system,
given that you're an evolved organism,
what have been the most permanent
features of your evolutionary history to
which you've adapted?
And I'm going to talk about some that
are more complex than the fact that the
ground beneath your feet is generally
from we obviously we've adapted to that,
you know,
and we've adapted to the presence of
light and we've adapted to the presence
of an atmosphere and so forth.
Those are all very constant phenomena.
But then there are constants of social
being that are virtually as old.
And we've talked about that a little
bit.
One of them I posited was the dominance
hierarchy.
I gave you some evidence that that's at
least 400 million years old.
But then there's also the fact of sexual
differentiation.
You know,
one of the fundamental facts of human
being and human social being is that
there are roughly speaking two genders
and that that's permanent.
So a masculine element of the social
world and a feminine element of the
social world are constants just as the
social world is a constant.
And then I would say mothers and fathers
are very constant.
There is constant as mammals are,
right?
So because we've had mothers and
fathers,
roughly speaking since we became
mammals,
and there are some reptiles that are
actually manifest some pretty decent
parental behavior and it occurs in birds
as well.
So,
and even in fish.
So you know,
it's pretty constant.
And then I would say the figure of the
child is constant and to figure of the
old man and the old woman are constants
and there's some more important
constants that are necessary to
consider.
Uh,
one constant is that you have a
territory.
The other constant is that there's
something outside that territory.
Another constant constant is that you
can be a pro,
you can be prayed for a predator.
That's a big one.
And then another constant is there are
predators.
Okay.
So your conceptual systems,
the ones that you utilize today are
going to be grounded in representations,
embodied representations and conceptual
representations that have already
structured themselves in accordance with
the existence of those constants.
And you're drawing on them as part of
the representational system that orients
you in the world.
And weirdly enough,
it actually works,
which is very peculiar thing as far as I
can tell.
So one of the things that's struck me as
in some sense in comprehensible is that
the use of these fundamental cognitive
categories too,
when you apply them to a world that in
some sense isn't objectively configured
in accordance with those conceptions.
It works,
it functions if you,
if it actually applies so that you can
live using those categories and you're
successful.
So anyways,
that's a tough one.
So,
so as we move,
so because so I said,
well you've,
you have to have a frame of reference in
the frame of reference is cybernetic.
And then there's an analogy between the
cybernetic structure and an at a
narrative structure.
And that's a very tight analogy.
It's likely an identity.
Okay.
So that's,
that's a set of premises.
The next premise is that within those
narratives there are constants of
representation and action and that those
are human procedural,
universal.
So things that we do.
And then there are,
there are human conceptual universals
and those conceptual universals,
the grounding of those conceptual
universals is in ancient biological
systems that had to conceptualize that,
that failed if they didn't conceptualize
a certain realm of constance in the
environment.
And I laid out the constance masculinity
femininity,
youth,
old age.
Okay.
Explored territory,
unexplored territory,
prey and Predator.
Now,
I'm not saying that's all of them
because I don't think it is all of them,
but we can get an awful long way with
just those.
Now if you read terror management
theorists,
the terror management theorists will
tell you something like your belief
system,
which is kind of conceptualized as a
system of interrelated abstractions,
prevents you from terror of death.
All right,
so that's Ernest Becker.
That's her inspectors theory.
It's pretty good theory.
It was grounded on Friday and
presuppositions and he developed that
theory in a book called the denial of
death,
which is also a pretty good book.
There's a problem with the basic theory
as far as I can tell though,
well,
there's multiple problems.
It's not a bad theory and at certain
levels of analysis,
it's a pretty good theory,
but it,
it has serious flaws.
The first flaw is your belief system is
not merely conceptual.
You act it out and that's really
important and so,
and it isn't also not the belief system
that protects you.
It's the fact that other people have
organized a society around you
predicated on that belief system and the
society works like it's not a
psychological society isn't a
psychological phenomena.
You have a representation of it and the
representation in part as a
psychological phenomena,
but the fact that you can sit here in
relative peace,
harmony,
security,
warmth,
and light is not a psychological
phenomenon.
It's embedded in the world,
so a lot of what protects you from
death.
Anxiety isn't a psychological structure
that stops you from being afraid.
It's an actual structure that stops you
from dying,
and so both are right,
but you can't forget about the most
fundamental one,
right?
The most fundamental one is the most
fundamental one,
and if,
if an event's so occur,
maybe even social conflict,
and I perceived that the consequences of
that social conflict is not only a
direct disruption of what I believe,
but also a disruption of the society
that that protects and shelters me.
Then of course I'm going to respond
negatively to that,
and it's not for only for merely
conceptual reasons.
It's because if the substructure of the
is actually destroyed,
I'm going to freeze to death in the dark
immediately.
So we don't want to oversight the law.
We don't want to make things more
psychological than they actually are.
And we have to remember that these
structures,
the dominance hierarchy is represented,
but it also exists out there in the
world.
And it's a real thing.
Okay,
now we're going to progress through some
models of emotional processing and then
some neuropsychological models,
and then we're going to get to the
symbolic domain.
That's that.
That's what's going to happen now.
So you're going from point a to point B
and you're looking at the world through
that framework.
So that framework also configures your
perceptions and it also configures your
emotional responses.
And so it's variable,
but within the variability,
there are constants and the constants
are you're going somewhere,
you come from somewhere,
and when you go from one to the other,
there's only three things that can
happen,
something you want,
that's a good thing that gets you to
where you're going and it validates the
theoretical integrity of your perceptual
frame.
That's an important thing,
right?
It,
it does two things.
You get to where you're going and it
provides evidence that your current
model is actually function.
So if you fail,
both of those things go into question.
One is you're not getting where you want
to go,
that's a problem.
But the worst one is,
oh,
the whole system that you're using to
try to get to where you go also might be
wrong and you don't know where.
Okay,
so that's
things that happen the way you want them
to happen.
That gets you to where you're going,
validates your model that produces
positive emotion.
The way it produces positive emotion is
by activating the dopaminergic system.
The dopaminergic system is embedded,
it has its roots in the hypothalamus and
the hypothalamus is roughly split into
two parts.
One part pops up sub personalities that
are charged with dealing with
fundamental biological necessities.
So aggression,
hunger,
thirst,
sexual activity,
temperature regulation.
You know the real basic animal like
drive,
so to speak,
that have to be gratified in order for
you to survive.
Half the hypothalamus deals with those
things.
And then the other half deals with
exploration.
And so that's pretty cool because what
it implies is that the urge to explore,
okay,
and the capability of responding to
things that serve as markers on your way
to a goal.
That system is about as old from a file,
a genetic perspective as the systems
that regulate such things as hunger is a
very,
very fundamental,
it's fundamental and deeply rooted
system.
And so we're not talking about something
that's peripheral or that's only
cognitive or it's only a manifestation
of a few thousand years of culture.
It's deep and it's so deep that you
can't even fight with it.
So for example,
part of the reason that you can tolerate
being alive is because when you're
progressing towards goals that you
regard as valid and when you're making
progress,
the dopaminergic system kicks in,
it's an approach system.
It kicks in,
it makes you feel good.
So there's a positive emotional element
to that,
which is sort of like it's okay to
engage with the world.
That's sort of the message of that.
It also facilitates certain kinds of
learning because it basically says since
what you're doing right now is working,
it's okay if you learn how to do it
better.
So it reinforces it,
right?
That's part of the reinforcement
structure.
And then it also suppresses anxiety and
pain.
So for example,
I don't know if you know this or not,
but cocaine is a pretty good analgesic.
And if you mix cocaine with opiates,
which is something to think about.
If you ever dying of intractable cancer
and you're in terrible pain.
If you Mitch mixed stimulants with
opiates,
you get a better pain medication than
either one of them alone.
Plus you stay alert,
which is also a useful thing to know.
So ritalin and opiates works as well.
So,
okay.
It's important to know that if you ever
know someone who's in severe,
intractable and final pain cause it can
be managed,
although doctors are loath to fix those
things,
but whatever.
Okay.
So when does the dopaminergic system
that manifest itself?
Well under two conditions.
One is when you're moving towards a
valued goal and the signs are that
you're actually succeeding in your
movement towards it.
And part of that is because the
dopaminergic system responds to cues of
conservatory reward and Consumer Tory
reward is any reward that brings the
perceptual system,
we'll call it the sub personality to a
halt.
So for example,
if you're hungry,
then as long as you're hungry and in
that frame of mind than anything
associated with food is going to be
reinforcing in a dopaminergic Lee
mediated way.
Technically that's incentive reward.
But as soon as you eat well,
then that frame of reference is no
longer relevant,
it disappears,
and then food isn't reinforcing.
Even though it's interesting,
hey,
because you might think that one of the
ways that you could stop eating when
you'd had enough is that food would stop
tasting,
but it doesn't.
Right?
It's kind of weird.
The food still tastes the same,
roughly speaking,
but it's no longer enjoyable.
And the reason for that actually is that
the,
the taste system has two elements that
are separated physiologically.
One of them is responsible for taste.
And it's also responsible for sort of
making,
you want to crave different foods during
an eating episode.
So there's actually a separate one for
sweets,
for example.
And so you can satiate the others and
not satiate the sweet receptors.
And then you want some dessert.
So any,
and if you keep rewarding that system
with dessert,
then it's going to get more and more
powerful.
But there's another system that sits on
top of that that acts independently.
And it's job is to say how good each of
those tastes now are.
And so as you get satiated,
what happens is that system just shuts
down.
It stops associating the tastes with
reward.
So you know,
it's kind of a cool way of setting it
up.
I think you can still taste things which
you need to do because you're an
omnivore.
And if you couldn't taste things well
then you die because you put something
stupid in your mouth and that'd be the
end of you.
So you can maintain the taste.
But the reward varies.
So the dopaminergic system responds to
incentive reward,
which is accused that a consumer reward
our forthcoming from a behavioral
perspective and the Conservatory reward
stops the action of the cycle.
And then another system that needs a
conservatory reward pops up.
So in some sense what's happening is
that you're continually subject to the
emergence of new motivated
subpersonalities or frames of reference
and you're just cycling through those
things all the time.
And then you might say,
well,
what happens if you are in some
favorable state and you've just satiated
everything?
And answer to that is you'll find the
environment itself,
mildly curiosity,
inspiring.
The dopaminergic system will make
exploring novelty rewarding.
And so you'll go out and you'll do some
random exploration because what the
hell,
you might as well do something while
you're awake and that will increase your
realm of competence and the the the size
of your explored territory.
And that's a fundament.
That's a very fundamental,
it's not a drive.
It's a very fundamental subpersonality.
It's,
and the reason I'm telling you that it's
nested in the hypothalamus is because I
don't want you to be thinking that this
is some new thing.
It's really,
really old.
It's,
it's probably about as old as pain and
its older I think than anxiety because
anxiety seems to be manifested mostly as
a consequence of higher order cognitive
and emotional systems that evolved after
the hypothalamus evolved,
roughly speaking.
So,
okay,
so when you're on your way somewhere,
good things or bad things can happen.
If good things happen,
you get a dopamine kick and that keeps
you focused on your goal and it
validates your theory and you get to
move to where you're going and you get a
consumer Tory reward and good for you.
That's success.
Except that a new frame of reference
pops up and you have the same problem
that sizzle,
right?
You're always pushing the damn rock up
the hill.
It's always rolling back down.
Question is,
do you find any delight and pushing the
rock up the hill.
So the other thing that can happen is
something you don't want to have happen.
And that thing indicates that you're not
getting to where you're going.
Now the question is,
what should you do when you find out
that you're not getting where you want
to go?
And the answer to that is you don't
actually know.
You actually don't know.
And this is where things get complicated
because on the one hand you could say
you could run into a known obstacle.
You remember Rumsfeld,
there are known unknowns and unknown
unknowns.
No,
that's probably,
you're probably too young for that.
Anyways,
if I'm walking towards the door and I
encounter this table,
then that's going to frustrate and annoy
me.
But it's only going to do it to a
limited degree because I can make a very
trivial correction in trajectory and I
can get to the door.
And so I would say,
well that's just an obstacle.
It's,
it's an obstacle.
I know its features.
I have a prearranged Schema of
conception and action so that I can
render it irrelevant with very little
effort.
Okay.
So it's a known obstacle,
but then that's fine.
So those are just negative things and
you try to get them out of your way.
So for example,
that's partly why you clean up your
house,
right?
Because you want your house to be in
order so that if you're doing things in
there,
things don't get in your way and annoy
you.
It just makes it more efficient.
So basically what you're doing doing is
trying to ensure that the paths you
take,
two desired ends are clear.
That's what it means to have a place in
order.
So it'll,
you know,
it means also the next thing,
which is even more important,
which is fine.
Sometimes you're walking from point a to
point B and a table gets in the way and
it's like you're a little annoyed that
you go around it.
That's not a problem.
And sometimes something else happens.
So my old supervisor had this dog and he
used to take it for a walk.
It's like every,
you can take your dog for a walk.
It's no problem.
So one day he was walking along the curb
and his dog pulled him a little bit into
the street and he fell.
And he shattered his leg like in seven
places and it was just,
there was nothing wrong with them
physically.
It's just that he fell wrong and like
poof,
he was,
and they had to put a bunch of plates in
there.
It's like,
hmm,
that's a whole different category of
event,
right?
It's,
it's the magnitude of that negative
thing is very large compared to just
running into a table.
And then,
okay fine,
there's hospitals and everything.
So he got dealt with and he was put back
together and even his fear of the event
would be bounded by his knowledge that
there is a hypothetical means of dealing
with the unexpected occurrence.
So it's nasty,
but it's not as nasty as things that you
don't know what to do with that all.
And those are things you encounter in
life too.
And so I've given you some examples of
those before.
A betrayal's a big one.
And I think the reason betrayal is such
a big one is because first,
if you're going to form a partnership or
a friendship with someone,
you're staking a lot of your life on
that,
right?
Because you're staking your future on
it,
you're staking your present on it.
It's,
it's an important presumption of the
nature of your reality moving forward.
So the next thing is,
is that when someone betrays you,
they violate your model of what it means
to be human.
And that's a big problem because you're
dealing with humans all the time.
And you're also a human.
So if,
if you're betrayed,
that casts the validity of the entire
structure you use to orient yourself
with regards to yourself and in the
social world into disarray.
So that's a very big explosion of
snakes.
And so,
you know,
I could say,
well people are full of snakes and you
might say,
well what does that mean?
It means that something like during our
evolutionary history,
predatory reptiles were a big problem.
So for example,
when we used to live in trees,
then tree dwelling snakes would eat us
and our offspring more likely,
cause that would be easier.
So that's a big problem.
It lasted some tens of millions of
years.
It's not a trivial amount of time.
And then there was,
when we're on the belt and we're going
down to get a nice drink of water and
then there's a Nile crocodile down there
and he's comes up and snaps you and
pulls you in.
So that subterranean predatory reptiles
really sort of make us nervous.
And you know,
perhaps that's why people think snakes
are slimy and they're not.
But if you talk to someone who's afraid
of a snake,
they'll say,
oh,
it's slimy.
It's like,
well no,
an underwater reptile might be slimy and
a snake is quite a lot like an
underwater reptile.
And who cares how they're different.
The question is,
the relevant issue is how they're the
same.
And so you could say,
well this is one of the categories.
It's horrible Predator that lurks.
That's a category.
Now I think that what happens when we
run into something that's radically
unexpected is that we use are horrible
Predator category to get ready for it.
And so that's partly,
I think also why the terror management
theories aren't exactly right.
Like we have some evidence from our lab
that I've really been wrestling with
over the last few years because one of
the things we found is that
conscientious people are more
conservative,
so they tend more towards right wing
authoritarian viewpoints.
And you can parse conscientiousness up
into two elements,
industriousness,
and that sort of predicts academic
performance and success in life and
orderliness.
Orderliness predicts right wing
authoritarianism,
and you might think,
well,
that's no surprise,
it's like authoritarians orderly,
but it's a bloody big surprise.
I can tell you that because we've been
trying to localize the position of
authoritarianism in the personality
hierarchy for 50 years and for the
longest period of time,
people thought that the reason that
people were conservative and right wing
is because they were afraid,
but it turns out that's not true.
They're lower in neuroticism than
liberals.
And you could say,
well,
that's because they're so well protected
by the rigid theories that they'd never
have to expose themselves to anything.
That's frightening.
But if you could use your damn theory to
predict results that are opposite to
what you predict,
you know,
it's really not much of a theory.
So I think it's better just to take the
data on the face of it.
Conservatives are higher and wellbeing
and their lower in neuroticism.
Now it's not a huge difference,
but it's,
it's different enough.
However,
orderly people are high in disgust,
sensitivity.
And that's a whole new realm of horrors
because disgust sensitivity is the
action of an intrinsic biological system
that stops you from being contaminated
and contamination kills you if it's
contaminate,
if you're contaminated enough.
So here's one way of thinking about it.
So what happened to the native Americans
when the Europeans showed up?
95% of them died,
right?
Measles,
they didn't.
Measles wasn't good.
Moms,
smallpox,
fatal.
So you know,
you shake hands with someone from Spain
and Poof,
250 million people are dead.
It's like,
so you think about that over the course
of evolutionary history,
like this is still happening,
by the way.
So you know,
there's still isolated tribes in the
Amazon.
And so when the miners or the oil,
you know the oil explorers or whatever,
go into the jungle and they find a new
tribe,
it's like they interacted,
poof,
then the whole tribe's dead.
And so you think how often in our
evolutionary history has it been the
case that when we encountered a group
that had been separated us from,
from us historically,
that one or the other of the group just
basically all died.
God only knows and we are.
So that's something to think about
because what's one of the things that
seems to happen is that we associate the
strange and unknown and foreign with the
disgusting and contaminating as well as
with the frightening and uncontrollable.
And I think the best way to
conceptualize that is as a global pred
prey Predator response.
We're responding using the biological
systems that we originally used to
protect us from predators that were
lurking.
And I don't know if you've ever might,
my daughter picked up a garter snake at
one point and the males exude this sort
of sticky substance that's protective
that I tell you,
man,
there is nothing in the world that
smells worse than that.
It's just indescribably horrible.
And she used to keep snakes in her room
and um,
she'd have nightmares about snakes
fairly often,
which I thought was quite interesting
because I think it was probably an old
factory issue.
But again,
their,
uh,
their biological byproducts shall we
say,
are unbearably disgusting.
And so well,
what should be the response to a
predator?
Hard to say,
but discussed is pretty good to go along
with fear and apprehension and
readiness.
And so,
so,
so.
All right.
So then you might say,
well how is that associated with the
fact of the unknown?
So because I was talking about betrayal,
said if you'd be traced someone,
then what happens basically is that you
manifest yourself as a set of snakes.
And I said,
well,
why,
why?
How can I justify a statement like that?
And the answer is,
first of all,
don't be thinking that we've never been
preyed upon by each other.
Cause that's definitely wrong.
You know,
humans are a very murderous lock and
we'd been running back and forth across
the surface of the earth,
wiping each other out for a very long
period of time.
So the idea that you're full of snakes
is a perfectly adequate idea except
maybe it's,
you know,
you're full of Nile crocodiles except
you're even worse cause you have a huge
brain in weapons.
You're one nasty thing and so to,
for me to respond to you,
revealing yourself as something other
than what I expected as if you were a
Predator is a perfectly reasonable thing
to do.
And in fact,
if you'd be traced someone,
it fundamentally is the case that you've
been a Predator in relationship to them.
You know,
it's more of an abstract Predator in
that you've been taking advantage of
them.
But who cares?
It's close enough so that it'll work.
So if you understand,
if you understand,
if you're willing to accept the idea
that you use the same systems to deal
with profound anomalies that your
ancestors used to deal with predators,
then there's a whole bunch of things
that start to become clear.
One of them is the symbolism that's
associated with the unknown,
but the other is the pronounced human
tendency to demonize the foreigner.
So we don't demonize the foreigner.
We demonize them.
Once we get to know them,
they start out demonic,
they start out as prey predators,
and it's very difficult for us to pull
back from that.
Now,
I'm not saying that's the only way we
respond to people who are different than
us because you know there are unknown
and the unknown is complex and there's
promising that too,
but we know that for human beings,
negative emotions are far more powerful.
Pound for pound,
let's say.
Then positive emotions and the
appropriate way for me to respond to you
if I don't know you is to start out with
the presupposition that maybe you'll
kill me.
Now,
I don't know if you know how isolated
tribes start to trade with each other.
It's pretty interesting.
So maybe they'll get some idea that
there's another tribe around and so,
and maybe they'll observe that that
tribe is doing something or rather that
might be interesting.
And so what they'll do is they'll find a
border between the two territories and
they'll leave things that might be
valuable there and then they'll run the
hell away.
And then maybe what will happen is the
other tribal come along and if they want
those things,
they'll pick them up and they'll leave
some other things that are valuable that
maybe they make behind.
And then,
you know,
that's the beginning of,
that's the beginning of trust,
but it's certainly not,
you know,
we run up to each other and see what the
hell is going to go on right off the bat
because God only knows what's going to
happen if you do that.
And so we,
it's reasonable for us to conceptualize
the foreign other as a predatory entity,
even though obviously that has all sorts
of catastrophic consequences,
but it doesn't matter.
Like if you want to fix that,
you have to understand why it's
happening.
So it isn't that we attribute to the
strange person and the strange idea or
the foreigner what's negative fro from a
conscious cognitive perspective.
Although we might also do that.
It's that,
that's just the way we are with regards
to things that we cannot conceptualize
or frame in question.
Yup.
Okay.
So you'll have to make that a little bit
more specific.
Right.
Well I would say the reason that Ebay
worked is because all it was all the
members of the same tribe that were
doing it.
We'd already laid down rules for trading
that everyone really understands and we
automatically engage in so we could just
transfer what we already knew about
trading to the new domain.
So,
well I think it's the basis of
reciprocity.
It's basically sharing,
you know,
in human beings are deeply sharing
creatures.
You know,
it's one of the things to think about
when you're thinking about us wandering
around desecrating the planet.
We're really good at sharing and other
animals aren't good at that at all.
Generally speaking.
And so sharing and trading.
Okay.
Trading is sharing over long
run,
right?
Because you know,
if I,
if I'm only sharing with you that's,
and you're not sharing with me,
that's going to get pretty damn boring
pretty quick.
And so you're going to be very careful
about reciprocity arrangements and so
that can keep the sharing going.
And that's basically what trade is.
So okay,
now you're going along and
you can encounter positive things that
you can encounter negative things,
and then you can encounter the category
of things that you don't understand.
And the question is,
the fundamental question is what should
you be doing about the category of
things that you don't understand?
So I'm going to go back to
this finger.
I hope this is it.
Oh good.
So we're going to try to understand
this.
You're betrayed by someone,
okay?
You had them in the good person
category.
All right?
Now they're not in the good person
category.
All right?
So exactly what are they like?
And the answer to that is,
while all these sub routines are up for
grabs,
you don't know what any of them are
composed of anymore.
So in some sense the fact that the
person has betrayed you,
reveals to you their potential inner
complexity,
and it also reveals to you the potential
potential potential inner complexity of
beings in general.
All right.
Now you might want to say if something
unexpected happens,
how should you calibrate your emotional
responses?
And the answer to that,
because the problem is here is that
responding to novelty turns out to be a
very complicated phenomena.
And the reason for that is that novelty
or a normally is a very complicated
category.
And the reason for that is that
sometimes when unexpected things happen
to you,
they're good.
And other times when unexpected things
happen to you,
they're bad.
And that means that they're a
paradoxical category.
There are category two,
which the rules of logic do not apply
because they can be be a not be your Aa
and na Aa at the same time.
It's,
it's not a good thing.
So if something unexpected happens to
you,
what's the appropriate way to respond
and answer to that is,
well,
you do a firsthand approximation when
the unexpected thing first reveals
itself.
Then basically you adopt the stance of
this might be a fatal predatory
manifestation and then pretty rapidly if
nothing else happens,
you're going to loosen up and start to
infer that the unexpected thing isn't as
catastrophic as you thought it would be.
The question is,
how do you determine the difference
between levels of catastrophic,
unexpected events and answer to me seems
to be found in this idea of the
hierarchical structure.
Is that all right person?
Be Tracy?
The idea that there are a good person no
longer holds,
that's very upsetting.
Why is it upsetting?
Oh,
here's the answer.
If a person is good,
how do they behave in every situation
like a good person?
If they're not good,
how do they behave in every situation?
Now answer to that is you don't have a
clue how they're going to behave.
So man,
they're all of a sudden extraordinarily
complicated and so we could go through
this.
Okay.
If you do a,
let's say you play with the baby and you
make it cry.
All right,
so,
and that's unexpected.
You're playing with baby,
poof,
it cries,
it's all upset about it.
So then what do you think about
yourself?
You think,
I'm not a good person because I make
babies cry.
It's like,
you know,
it's a reasonable inference,
right?
But you probably don't want to
immediately leap to that conclusion.
It's an anomaly.
The baby cried.
It isn't what you wanted.
So you've got to frame that.
And normally in,
because it could be,
you know,
maybe the mother comes running in and
says,
Huh,
I got a story about this.
So one of my friends,
he's kind of a wild guy and he was
babysitting his daughter at another
woman,
a woman started from down the street.
Hey.
And so he plays with them and he plays
with them,
you know,
pretty intensely.
And so the kids love that except when
they don't.
So,
so what he's doing is he likes to chase
his daughter around with this remote
control car,
you know,
so he's chasing his daughter round with
this remote control car.
And she's having a fine time and her
friend is there and she's also running
away from the remote control car.
And uh,
you know,
they're having fun and then the two
girls run into the closet and hide.
And so my friend is like roaring the car
up against the,
the,
uh,
outside of the closet and scratching at
it a little bit then.
And then his daughter says,
Daddy,
you have to stop.
Uh,
my friend is crying and it's for real.
It's like,
okay.
So he's feeling pretty bad about that.
So he takes the little kids out and he's
picking up the daughter and given her a
pat,
and then she's pretty upset.
She's wailing away about this.
And then the doorbell rings and it's the
girl's mother.
And then he's thinking,
Huh,
I just chased this girl into the closet
and then made like scratchy monster
noises on outside and now she's really
upset.
How exactly am I going to explain this
in a way that doesn't make me look like
a pathological beast?
So,
hey,
here's kind of a pathological beast.
So it's a good question.
But anyways,
you see that,
you see,
hopefully you see the point there.
So all right,
now the question that he posed to his
neighbor was,
where in the hierarchy did I go wrong?
And what he was afraid of was that her
response would be if you chase my child
into the closet and then made monster
noises and scared her so much that she's
this upset,
that doesn't mean you don't know how to
play with the baby.
That means that you are not a good
person.
Right?
Right,
right.
So,
so you can see how that inference can
propagate itself up this chain.
Now,
generally speaking,
if you make an error like that,
you should make the presupposition that
one of your local routines is at fault.
And you should also make that
proposition in relationship to whoever
might be making a mistake like that
around you.
You should start from the high
resolution level and say,
well,
maybe they are missing a micro skill
instead of the low resolution level,
which is they're a bad person.
Now the problem with that sometimes is
it the reason that things didn't go well
for them is that they are a bad person.
But probably you should explore that
possibility a bit before immediately
leaping to that conclusion.
Because if you do leap to that
conclusion and you're wrong,
that's also a huge problem.
The problem is is that when the
unexpected occurrence occurs,
like in this story,
the entire framework is up for debate
because you don't know how to localize
the,
the error and you don't know how to
localize its magnitude.
And so what your body will do is default
to the worst possible option at least
initially.
And then you,
and that makes sense cause that's a
defensive reaction,
right?
And so,
and that can really get out of hand.
I mean it got out of hand with the
daycare scandals in the 1980s when,
you know there were daycare centers all
over the United States and Canada where
there are these horrible stories
emerging of say,
titanic ritual abuse in the daycare
centers.
And it's like,
well that's pretty bad.
You'd go up to the top and you say,
you know,
not only are you not a good person,
you're actually Satan himself or you
know,
a pretty good,
uh,
pretty good,
what,
uh,
approximation,
a sufficiently good approximation.
So the title is,
is accurate.
So,
and that caused a lot of people a
tremendous amount of trouble.
But it's a perfectly,
it's an a priori,
undifferentiated natural response.
And the category of Satan,
so to speak,
is individual human being has hyper
predator.
That's a perfectly reasonable category
because individual human beings are
hyper predators.
So luckily enough,
that's not all we are.
So,
all right.
So the idea in some sense is that when
you're walking along and something
unexpected happens to you,
you basically fall into a hole in the
hole,
is the complexity that's underlying your
presuppositions.
And that's a whole different place.
And then the next proposition I would
say to a next proposition I would like
to lay out is that we actually represent
that domain symbolically.
And we represented first of all,
often as a whole.
So it's the,
it's the water you plunge into when the
ice beneath your feet breaks the thin
ice.
You're always skating on.
It's the underworld of the ancients.
It's hell.
It's the place you go when you're
desperate and anxious and unhappy.
Um,
it's the source of all terrible things.
But at the same time,
it's also the source of all possibility,
because as the unexpected itself,
as the anomalous itself,
it's not only everything that can
terrify and destroy you,
but it's also everything new that can
emerge as a consequence of old habits
and presuppositions falling apart.
There were erroneous.
And so I would say one level of
representation that we use for that
domain and for the Denisons of that
domain is prey animal.
And so that's roughly toothy reptile.
And that can be subterranean toothy
reptile,
or it can be under the oceans toothy
reptile and,
and their variants of that.
And they take monstrous form,
you know,
so it's a complex of,
of things that will destroy you in a
predatory manner.
So that's one domain of symbolism.
The other domain of symbolism is that
which I lies outside tribal territory.
That's no man's land and no man's land
is in a complicated way.
That's where you go when you're
culturally sanctioned.
Presuppositions do no longer function.
It's a weird thing because on the one
hand you could go outside the borders of
your community,
you know,
as a physical act.
On the other hand,
you can go outside the metaphysical
boundaries of your community by acting
out a culturally sanctified role and
failing.
Cause as soon as you fail,
then you're somewhere that your culture
isn't.
And that's for all intents and purposes,
that's unexplored territory.
It's not just a metaphor,
it's actually the case.
It's just the idea of territory is much
more complicated.
And then the other domain that seems to
be consistently used to represent the
unknown as such is the feminine.
And the reason for that,
as far as I can tell,
we talked about this a little bit,
is that females are actually the
gatekeepers to propagation among human
beings.
And so the idea that they should be
symbolically represented by the terrible
and re rejecting element of nature is
perfectly reasonable perspective,
even though it's harsh,
but also because the unknown is not only
the place where terrible things happen,
it's also the place where everything new
was born,
so to speak.
And the most salient characteristic of
the feminine is that the feminine is the
place where new things are born.
And we had to use some damn category for
it,
you know,
and we only had a certain number of
categories at hand because of our
biological evolution.
So what happens is you're wandering
around in your life and then you fall
into a hole.
And the question is how big is the hole?
And at the moment you're falling,
you don't know.
So I have another story.
So I had a friend who was,
he used to hang out in the bush and
British Columbia and now and then he
would be tromping around their owed in
the winter and sometimes he'd crossed
rivers.
And one time he was crossing a river
that was covered with snow and he fell
through the surface.
Now he was very lucky because what he
had fallen through was a bubble of ice.
So we sell about four feet and he hit
the ice again.
But you can imagine what must have been
going on in his little sphere of the
world during the one 10th of a second
where he was falling before he hit the
new ice.
Well that's,
that's a good story to indicate,
you know,
the similarity between the unexpected
and falling into the underworld.
And one of the things that I think is
extraordinarily useful is that once you
guys know that the idea of a journey to
the underworld is the same thing as the
idea of the validity of your conceptual
structures breaking out from underneath
you and plunging you into the complexity
that characterize his life,
then you have one of the keys that you
need to understand mythology.
And that's a big deal because most of
our history,
like our cultural history is presented
to us in the form of extraordinarily
ancient stories.
And the categories those stories use are
as far as I can tell,
are the categories that I'm outlining to
you.
And once you know what the categories
mean,
then you can read the stories and they
make sense.
And that's a mind bogglingly important
thing because some of the stories that
we're going to be studying,
like people worked on those things for
150,000
years,
you know,
and now maybe that's an overstatement,
but we certainly know that they worked
on them for thousands of years.
And if you can't understand them,
it's a big problem.
You know,
before maybe you could just believe
them,
whatever that meant.
But people,
modern people can't do that anymore
because partly because I think because
we've developed that a new kind of
cognitive system that essentially
response to the world as if it's a place
of objective material,
but,
and that's fine.
It's really useful.
Maybe it'll kill us,
but it's certainly useful.
But then there's this other cognitive
domain that we actually have to
understand because without it,
we're bereft of our history and our,
our values are the bedrock values that
we use to orient ourselves in time and
space and to protect us from the
catastrophic release of our emotions.
All of that's invalidated.
And you might say,
well,
you know,
does that really matter?
And it's like,
well,
I don't know how many of you have gone
through nihilistic periods in your life,
but I suspect that it's more than one or
two.
So that's one danger is that when the,
when,
when the validity of your value system
is,
is demolished,
then you end up in a place where
everything's so terrible and
overwhelming that you cannot survive.
And one response to that is you become
nihilistic and depressed and anxious,
and that's not merely psychological.
That's really hard on you.
It can undermine your entire wheel to
live,
can even drive you to suicide.
And other option is you adopt some
moronic totalitarian ideology that
purports to explain everything with a
few simple axioms.
And that's each equally catastrophic
because that makes you immediately a
danger to anyone who doesn't believe
what you believe.
Plus you're fragile because you know,
if it's a simplistic but coherent
ideology,
like the idea that all knowledge systems
are motivated only by the pursuit of
power,
it's like good luck implementing that in
the world.
You know,
you'll find out pretty soon that that
sort of theory is just not going to get
you anywhere at all.
So it makes you brittle and fragile.
So.
All right,
so I'm going to stop and let you ask
questions because I,
I threw a lot of information at you in
the last three weeks and what I want to
do now,
I'm going to,
the next thing is I'm going to tell you
a little bit about the brain areas that
are associated with the information,
information processing phenomena that I
described.
So like one of the things that's quite
interesting apart from the fact that the
exploratory system is grounded in the
Hypothalamus,
which is mind boggling,
mind boggling stock given how the
hypothalamus operates,
is that your right hemisphere,
if you're lefthanded and relatively
lateralized in the approximately
normative manner,
your right hemisphere basically deals
with novelty and anomaly and your left
hemisphere deals with explored
territory.
So it's sort of like you have,
your brain is split in a manner.
So that one part of it,
which is mostly responsible for negative
emotions.
So that's the right hemisphere is kind
of good at global pattern,
global quick pattern recognition and it
responds to anomaly and novelty with its
initial formulations of what might be
there.
And then the left hemisphere is
specialized for operation and explored
territory.
So the left hemisphere is primarily
what's operating when you're somewhere
that you understand and everything is
going according to plan.
And it's pretty damn interesting.
You can,
if you,
you know,
if you're dubious about the validity of
this theory,
you could look up elk Colon Goldberg.
So He's,
he's one of the people who've proposed
the novelty,
uh,
unexplored territory explored territory
dichotomy with regards to Brayden
hemispheric specialization.
And Goldberg was a student of Luria and
Gloria was a student of Pavlov.
And like,
there's a pretty vicious intellectual
history there.
So it's not something to be dispensed
with lightly.
Um,
he thinks the reason that the left
hemisphere is linguistic,
roughly speaking,
is because it,
it,
because the ability do you use
linguistic systems is one of its
preconditions is that you're operating
in a domain where things are understood
and shared.
So,
so there's that.
And then there's the response of your
emotional systems that are at least in
part,
the hippocampus.
We mediated that outlined the manner in
which you respond to novelty.
So we're going to talk about both of
those things.
And the prefrontal cortex is very good
for exploration and abstract
representation.
So I'm going to lay out a bit of a brain
theory.
And then the next thing we're going to
do is start to look at narrative
patterns.
I,
I want to show you one more slide.
Sorry,
before,
before we,
I want to show you that one.
Now most of you have seen that probably
a multiple times.
Yeah,
but here's the idea.
You're going along just fine.
Something emerges from the depths so to
speak.
So it's some complex phenomena that was
here to,
for invisible that made its
manifestation.
It knocks the validity out of your
current mode of operation.
And it plunges you into a place chaotic
and complex,
where you flail about mostly a negative
emotion depending on how radical the
discontinuity is.
Cause if it's just a little one mile,
maybe you'll find it exciting.
But if it's a big one,
man,
you're down there in the dumps,
so to speak,
for a very long period of time.
Now with any luck,
and this is sort of piaget,
Eddie and idea,
you do some exploration and some
recategorize Zation you ingest the new
information that was associated with the
anomalous event.
So that's like the treasure that the
dragon guards and then park.
You pop up and you have a new framework
of reference and it's better than the
old one in that it does everything the
old one did.
Plus it accounts for the new thing that
brought you down.
Now if you can't do that and you've been
hit hard,
then you have something like post
traumatic stress disorder or an anxiety
disorder,
longterm depression and you're stuck
down there and chaos and the underworld
and maybe you never get back up.
So narrative,
narrative,
one point a to point B and here's how to
do it.
Narrative to what do you do when your
narrative falls apart?
That's a Meta narrative.
The narrative falls apart.
You fall somewhere,
something happens there that's
transformative or not and then you pop
back out.
So the Meta narrative is a narrative
about the transformation of narratives
and it's the Meta narrative that most
mythologies feature front and center
because it's basically the same as the
hero myth.
The hero myth.
The hero is the person who encounters
the anomalous and the unknown at a time
and place of their choosing.
Okay.
Garners the information,
which is the treasure that the anomalous
predatory thing guards.
And if it's a full hero myth,
shares that with the community in
reconstitutes themselves.
And that's the fundamental story of
mankind.
Yeah.
It's the fundamental story.
And if you understand the categories,
all right,
if you're,
I think if you understand the categories
in the manner that I laid out,
then you can understand those stories.
And that is so cool because they're so
powerful and they orient you properly.
And it,
it just demolishes the,
the nihilism and totalitarian belief
inducing elements of moral relativism
and the collapse of religious belief
systems because it can put some ground
underneath your feet again,
and it's,
it's important,
like it's,
it's a defense against it theology and
it's a get a defense against despair and
those things are attractive forces and
nihilism in particular.
It's like life is suffering.
Why shouldn't you be cynical about it?
Well,
that's a real question.
That question is no joke.
It's like,
just get on with it.
Yeah,
right.
That's not gonna help
ideology because of it.
It's a defense.
Again,
I can,
that's a good question.
This is a defense against ediology
because it,
it tells you something different about
the state of your being.
So here,
here's how it works.
You can be locked in your first system.
I don't care what the system is,
you're locked in it.
You're an idiot log.
Something comes along and blows your
system into bits.
You're in the underworld,
you're in chaos.
So it's,
you're either an idiot log or pretend
protected or poof,
you're blown into bits.
Okay.
Well then another identity you could
have instead of the identity of the
initial framework is you can have the
identity of being in chaos and then
you're sort of a nihilist.
You know,
you're fundamentally depressed,
you're cynical about the world,
it's hard for you to get motivated and
so forth.
So that's your identity.
Or You could have the identity that you
rebuilt after going through one of those
processes and you think,
well,
that'd be an improvement because it's a
better identity than the previous one,
and it's certainly a lot more pleasant
than being neck deep in snakes and
lizards.
And so,
so that's an improvement.
But then there's a step that you can
take this further that's better,
which is forget about identifying with
the first stage or the second stage,
which is the collapse or the third
stage.
Forget about all of that.
Realize that you're the process of doing
that.
That's what you are fundamentally,
so you don't have to identify with what
you believe and you don't know.
I have to identify with despair.
You can identify with the process of
coming to terms with the world as it
manifests itself.
And you do embody that process if you
want.
And not only that,
well,
you're engaged in that process.
Number one,
your engaged.
That's a good thing.
And number two,
the systems that protect you against
despair and pain.
So if you're going to think about it
biologically,
that would be the dopaminergic system.
Primarily that thing is on.
You're in the game,
but you're a player,
you're not the game.
And I believe that what religious
stories attempt to teach people among
very many other things is that you're
not the bloody game and you're not the
chaos of defeat.
You're the player and you play many
games and the meaning is in the playing
and it's not.
It's not a platitude that is actually
where the meaning is and the meaning is
it real?
And so then the question is,
the more fundamental question is,
is that meaning real enough to protect
you from cynicism and nihilism?
And answer to that is you have to figure
that out for yourself because no one can
tell you that.
But the stories can show you the way so
to speak,
which is why they're there.
When you said experience and what does
that mean?
So Dostoyevsky's in the prison after
getting arrested by the czar's men and
then six in the morning after a couple
of weeks in his cell,
they take them out into the courtyard
and shoot him with blanks.
Yeah.
That moment when he's standing there
before he's going to be shot.
That's a religious experience and the
thing it is,
it overwhelmed him to such a degree that
it basically gave him epilepsy,
so like full,
there's a reason I say that in the Old
Testament,
God is represented as the burning Bush.
It's like don't get too close to that
stuff.
It'll,
it's too much.
The reality that transcends your models
free.
Forget about personified representations
of the day and for the time being,
the reality that transcends your models
is sufficient so that if you're exposed
to it at an untrammeled manner,
it will hurt you.
It might destroy you and it's not a
trivial sort of objective experience.
It's like the law that rat feels when
it's trapped in the corner by a very
large cat,
terrorist stands up.
You know,
when you feel awe,
what happens?
Your hair stands on end.
Yeah.
Well there's a reason for that.
It's like the remnants of a prey
response.
So
also be enlightened.
Yeah,
but who wants that?
You know,
because of your,
your new age types and your Joseph
Campbell's,
they say,
well,
you know,
enlightenment,
it's all good.
It's like,
forget that.
Believe me,
if it was all good,
people would be doing it.
It's not all good.
And that's one of the major differences
say between the unions and the new age
people,
the new age people say,
follow your bliss.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
The union say,
look,
follow what you're interested in.
It will take you places you do not want
to go and you're not getting anywhere
until you go to those places.
And so everyone takes one look and says,
Hey,
no,
that theory's wrong.
It's like,
it's not wrong.
It's just very,
very difficult.
So enlightenment is down first and then
up and the more enlightened do you want
to get,
the more you go down before you go up?
Me Ask him that.
That's a harder question.
I think part of what enlightenment is
not,
is not hiding behind the shields of your
tentative belief systems.
That's one way of thinking about it.
Another way of thinking about it,
I think,
is that if you're engaged in a
conversation with someone with whom you
disagree,
the more you're enlightened,
the more you'll listen to them.
Because otherwise you have to prove to
them that the way you look at the world
is correct.
Well,
that's not an enlightened stance.
That's a dogmatic and totalitarian
stance.
It's like,
I'm right,
I'm right.
Here's why.
It's like,
fine.
Except if I'm right,
I already know what I'm writing about
and if you disagree with me,
there's always the possibility that you
know something I don't like horrifying
is that possibility is so listening to
you would be a good idea.
And so then another way of thinking
about that is you can think about this
yourself.
What's your friend?
What you know or what you don't know.
And part of identifying with the process
of transformation instead of the stages
of it,
is understand that what you don't know,
it's a more reliable friend than what
you know.
First of all,
there's a lot of it you're not going to
run out.
And second,
every time you encounter it
successfully,
the world becomes a more comprehensible
place and you become a more powerful
force.
So you know,
you could be running around all the time
looking for little things that you don't
know makes you tough and awake and
that's,
and if you're tough and awake,
maybe you don't have to believe things
to make sense out of life.
Maybe your life is so damn rich that you
think,
yeah,
well,
you know,
suffering,
disease,
death,
tyranny,
all that.
It's like,
yeah,
well I can deal with that.
I don't want to wish it away even though
I'd rather it wasn't there.
That's not the point.
It's like I can have my eyes open and
see that and still think,
no,
this is worth,
this is worth continuing.
Oh yeah.
Well,
through experience and training.
Yeah.
Because I mean,
think about it this way.
It's like you guys just don't have
enough life to figure everything out for
yourselves.
You know,
it's,
forget it,
you can't do it.
Life's too complicated.
Then you're too short.
You're life is too short and you're not
that smart,
you know?
And so unless you have guidance,
obviously people have to be socialized,
you know,
they have to be socialized or they're
just ruined.
The question is what's the end product
of the socialization?
One is well nihilistic,
totalitarian,
you know,
the other is the other is the person who
has one foot in order in one foot in
chaos.
And that's a better place to be because
the world isn't just order and it's not
just chaos
scientific.
Well I think that's what happened in the
20th century and that's what we're going
to take a look at.
Like part of the re I told talk to you
guys about nature and his announcement
at the end of the 19th century,
you know?
Okay.
So what are you,
is announcing his,
oh no.
Our new mode of thinking has invalidated
our old modes of thinking.
And that's not it.
It's like a mass.
It's like a giant,
it's like a murder of the most valuable
thing you can imagine.
That was his perspective.
And then his observation was look out.
Cause when something of that magnitude
dies,
there's a big void and something's going
to take its place.
So what took its place?
What's pretty all of this.
I mean communist totalitarianism took
its place.
That was pretty much half the planet.
We haven't quite,
you know,
scrapped all the problems that were
associated with that.
And then there's,
there's widespread nihilism and,
and,
and like a pathological form of
relativism.
So,
and for neat chair,
those were the two options.
It's like where else do you have to go?
Well
that's what happened and it wasn't good.
And I think,
you know,
it's like one of the things that Viktor
Frankl said about his clients,
his clinical clients and Frankl was a
psych psychologist who'd been through
the concentration camps.
You know,
he said that very frequently.
The problem that his clients came to him
about was the problem of meaning.
It's like the,
and I think who was it that said he
opened his book?
I think it was Camou the only
philosophical question worth posing is
why not commit suicide?
Now it's a little on the depressing
side,
but if you ever talk to someone who's
thinking about committing suicide,
I'll tell you,
they can come up with some pretty
comprehensive answers for why that's a
reasonable thing to do.
And you know,
you just don't leap there from happy to
suicidal.
You have to go through a lengthy process
of determining just exactly why suicide
is the appropriate option,
you know,
unless you're tremendously impulsive.
And so to me it's like if we lose our
grounding in history,
given that were historical creatures and
if we lose the proper sense of identity,
then we're either going to be weak or
dangerous.
Those are the options.
And if you're weak,
you're dangerous,
and if you're dangerous,
you're weak.
So like,
you know,
either way it's not good.
And I also think,
and this is skipping ahead in the class
a lot,
is to the degree that you think that
existence is unbearable because if it's
meaningless structure and it's implicit
suffering,
it's going to be a big chunk of your
psyche that's wandering down genocidal
and apocalyptic lanes.
Because if it's pointless misery,
why not put an end to it?
And you know,
if you don't think that people are
trying to figure that out all the time,
you're just not paying any attention
because people are trying to figure that
out all the time.
So,
and if you read,
okay,
the brothers Karamazov I think is the
best example of this.
You know,
Dostoyevsky has a figure in the brothers
Karamazov whose name is Ivan and Ivan's
a pretty vicious character.
He smart as can be.
He's good looking.
He gets along well with people,
he's,
you know,
he's debonair,
Suave and he's a committed nihilist and
he has a rational arguments to backup
his nihilism like that are the most
powerful ones Dostoyevsky could invent.
And so there are powerful enough,
like he's done as good a job as anybody
needs to.
And he puts forth a vicious argument for
the pointlessness and essential
immorality of existence.
Well,
maybe he's right,
maybe not.
That's the question.
So part of what I've been trying to
figure out is how could it be possible
that Ivan is wrong?
And if so,
why?
And that's what I'm trying to tell you
is that these that we think
of as archaic superstitions are not
theories about objective reality and
they're not archaic and they're not
superstitious.
And not only that,
you already live by their dictates in
one form or another,
whether you know it or not.
And they're,
the old stories are perennially
attractive to you and you need the,
you can't live without them.
So what I'm trying to do,
what I've tried to do is to figure out
how they can be true while still
allowing the other things that we know
as modern people to be true.
So that's what we're trying to figure
out.
Other questions,
it's the actual stories themselves.
You're trying to think of how can the
two religious stories be true?
Yeah,
and what it means for them to be true.
What that means.
Because one of the things we've been
doing over the last three weeks,
it's thinking what does it mean for
something to be true?
That is not a simple question.
And one idea is that theories about
objective world are the only form of
truth,
but that's not that.
First of all,
that can't,
that can't be true because your problem
is how to act and you might say,
well that's not a real problem.
It's like at at that point in the
discussion,
then we start talking about what's real
and what isn't.
Right.
It's such a deep question that the
nature of your term starts to become
important.
And I would say the most important
question that you have to answer is how
and why to live.
And you might think,
well that's an episode nominal question.
It's like,
well,
I don't,
I don't think it is.
And I don't think there's any evidence
that it is.
I think it's a proposition that it is,
and I don't think it's supported by the
fact,
and that's what you're going to be
trying to figure out while we go through
this course.
So other questions and if any of the
things I don't,
if I say don't make sense,
please tell me.
Because I know that I,
it's complicated thing to try to explain
religion,
that structure of beliefs too,
but actual religion dogma that goes with
that.
And people can take that more literally
as in the objective world.
Yeah.
The dogma is just the dominance
hierarchy.
So everything has a dogmatic structure.
That doesn't mean it's,
it's right.
I mean,
religions are generally made out of a,
forget about religions.
Belief systems have a dogmatic element
and a transformative element.
And they're always at war because one,
the,
the dogmatic element constraints,
the revelatory element and the
revelatory element undermines the
dogmatic element,
but they're both necessary.
So it's a very,
it's a form of dialogue.
It's the best way to think about,
there's gotta be a dialogue and belief
systems between the structure and the
process of updating the structure.
And,
and any belief system can err too much
one way or the other.
And the only reason way that you can
figure out if you're airing is by paying
attention and,
and,
and communicating.
So,
and if you want a definition of
religion,
well you know that's not a straight
forward thing to do but I would say that
you have that you have axioms of belief
and your axioms,
whatever they are are religious entities
for you whether you know it or not cause
you hold them as absolutely true and,
and you have insufficient evidence for
anything.
So you know,
this is a cure could guardian idea,
you are by necessity a creature of
faith.
And the reason for that is there isn't
much of you and there's a lot of the
world and so you have to make
assumptions in order to move forward.
And you might think,
well I don't make assumptions.
And then I would say,
well when you crossed the street,
you're making an assumption.
The assumption is that the other side of
the street is a better place to be than
this side of the street you're already
on.
So that's an assumption.
You know,
maybe you're going to get hit by a bus
as you cross,
you know so much for that axiom,
but you just can't move forward without
making assumptions because if you
question everything all the time,
then you're paralyzed.
You're in chaos.
So wondering story,
story,
the negative side and ideology,
which can be extreme.
So taking that
excellent question.
Well,
that's partly what we're going to talk
about a lot.
Um,
it's the difference between,
it's like the difference between surfing
and being in a styrofoam bubble on a
lake.
You know,
there's a dynamic element.
So if I say,
well,
if you're going to identify with the
process of transformation,
I'm,
first of all,
I'm not saying that's all you should
identify with.
That's,
that's a different question.
It might depend on where are you are and
what you're doing and at what stage of
life you are and all sorts of other
things.
But to the degree that you identify with
the process that transforms belief
systems,
you're not an idiot log.
It's as simple as that because in video
log is a totalitarian and they say,
well,
here's the bloody axioms.
Here's the system that generates,
we're done.
So you're not done and you've left
things out.
Now that doesn't mean you don't need
structure to move forward.
Right?
So it's a tricky thing,
but you can say,
that's why I'm trying to communicate to
you the idea that it's better to
conceptualize a belief system has a set
of tools.
They don't have to be perfect.
You know,
you can,
you can fix a pipe with a pretty lousy
wrench.
So you've got tools at your disposal and
you shouldn't abandon them.
We thank God for the tools,
you know?
But if you can think of a better tool,
it's more power to you.
So
it seems like the religious stories
might not help them.
It might knock them right out of the
bloody thing into a pit.
I mean,
I've had fundamentalist Christians in my
classes before,
you know,
and,
and it's pretty,
it rattles them up pretty hard because
they implicit,
they're kind of funny.
They're sorta like the rational atheist.
They tend to think of the religious
system as a theory about objective
reality.
It's so funny because they both share
that they both share the same priests
opposition.
And so,
you know,
I outlined evidence that it's not and
that that often is extraordinarily hard
on their fundamentalist viewpoint.
So,
but that's okay with me.
It's like,
yeah,
over time as,
as a culture.
And then that probably affected the core
of the belief system.
The religions too.
So not even they're fully understanding
what beliefs are actually helping them
with their lives.
Oh,
definitely not like,
I mean,
all of you people in this class or
uncover unconscious advocates of ancient
religious ideas,
like I don't care whether you know it or
not because otherwise you run into
Dostoyevsky's conundrum.
If there's no absolute morality he
really meant if there's no god,
then you can do anything you want.
Everything's up for grabs.
And so the question is,
do you run around doing anything you
want?
Or you can say,
well you don't because you're afraid.
It's like,
fine,
you can take that avenue.
I don't care.
That just puts it outside of the context
of this argument all together.
Why do you act morally?
Why should you,
why shouldn't you lie to get what you
want?
Or why should or should you?
Why shouldn't you steal to get what you
want or killed to get what you want?
Why not?
There's got to be answers to these
questions.
So obviously every three year old knows
that if you lie carefully,
you can get what you want.
So why not do it all the time?
Why not practice it until you're great
at it?
Like compulsive liar or sold to other
people?
Like it's almost like I find that
interesting that like people that do
that or like other people see it and
like really wrong.
So,
so I've got a story for you.
So if you go on a chip bunch of chimps
in a,
in a cage,
and you bring a snake in there,
even the plastic snake,
they'll all hit the ceiling,
get away from that snake.
But then they'll look at it and look at
it,
look at it.
And if a snake,
if a chimp comes across a big snake in
the wild,
they have a particular call they use,
which the primatologist caught a snake
rat,
which is w r a,
h.
So it's sort of like the sound the
chimps make.
So they make this noise and then all the
other chimps have come and they'll just
look at that snake,
like they stay a fair distance from it,
but they'll look at it and look at it
and look at it and look at it for hours
and hours and hours.
It's like dexter,
right,
right.
The serial killer contemptible object
and ever eternally fascinating.
It's the same sort of thing,
you know?
And so there's discussed and attraction
at the same time.
So
there's a relationship with Alexa,
the lack of not being able to feel
that will,
that's a good question.
So I Alexithymia is a hypothetical
psychiatric condition.
That's the consists of the inability to
articulate emotional states.
It's a good question because it depends
on the degree to which your personality
has to be articulated in order to be
functional.
And one of the things I would propose to
you,
and this is partly why we're doing the
exercises that we're doing,
is that just like imagine that if your
joints weren't articulated,
not very helpful cause you could just
sort of slap things with your hands,
you know,
they'd be like pause,
but they're fully articulated and
there's a conceptual relationship
between articulated speech and
articulation.
Articulated speech means that your tools
for dealing with the world are more
differentiated,
perceiving acting in the world.
And so the more you can articulate
yourself,
the more of you there is,
the more the world there is.
Hypothetically.
That's a good thing.
So if you're,
if you're without terms for emotions,
pretty damn hard to communicate.
Um,
what do you say some of the new age
concepts that the objective reality,
I guess that we're living right now in
terms of yes,
mate.
Yeah.
Maybe standing before for bliss and
falling intuition and trying to tap it.
Yeah.
Well,
a big part,
a big part of the new age movement is in
fact a reaction against rationalist
style Islam.
So to that degree,
there's some utility in it.
But the problem is,
is that it's sort of like protestantism,
the devil.
The world is all good.
Well no wrong,
that's not even close to right.
The world is a horrible place and people
are terrible creatures.
But that's not the whole story,
right?
Cause the world is also a wonderful
place and people are amazing creatures.
So,
but I think that's another answer to the
ideology question too,
is that in my understanding,
a philosophy that unites the opposites,
which is kind of a union idea,
is not an ideology.
So here's an ideology.
Human beings are despoiling the planet.
Western culture does nothing but rape
and pillage and nature is a,
uh,
innocent,
virginal victim.
It's like,
yeah,
that's all true,
but it's only half true because human
beings are all also unbelievably
interesting and remarkable creatures.
And it's no bloody wonder that we're
trying to survive.
And that has costs.
And thank God for culture because
otherwise,
you know it was minus 10 last night,
so we'd all be popsicles and nature is
doing everything it possibly can in
every moment to destroy and undermine
us.
So it's like,
okay,
you want an ideology,
you can pick the first one,
that's an environmental ideology.
The second one is like a frontier myth.
So you put them together and you've got
nature is terrible and beautiful and
culture is tyrannical and provide
security.
And the human being is,
you know,
a remarkable exploratory hero and an
absolutely satanic figure.
And then you've got the whole thing not
quite.
Cause there's one other category that
that is sort of like the category from
which all those categories emerge.
It's a very low level category.
But as far as I can tell,
a system that has representations of
those classes of phenomena is not an
ideology.
And I also think that's partly why it's
so damn hard to get rid of Freud because
freud categories map onto that map.
You know,
there's the Ed that's sort of nature and
it's great source of energy and it's
horrible.
And then there's the ego.
The Ego is,
you know,
pretty good thing with all sorts of
weird troubles and pathologies.
And then there's the Super Ego,
which is society.
You need that.
Otherwise you're out of control.
But it can also be a crushing and
tyrannical force.
It's like,
well you can't get rid of Freud because
he got story,
right.
And you might argue about is categories
and all that,
but doesn't really matter because
they're grounded in,
in something deeper than the terms that
Freud used.
So,
and if you see Christ,
any Disney movie that that's worth its
salt has all of those characters in it.
Otherwise it gets one sided like frozen,
which was an absolutely dismal and
wretched movie.
It was meant the law,
it was Disney is pretty good at
mythology,
but frozen frozen was pure radiology.
So it was very annoying to see that
because in most situations the Disney
movies are pretty good at balancing out
the archetypes.
So,
and that's part of the reason there's
there.
So once insanely popular know,
they present an architectural picture of
the world.
And the thing is,
you say,
well,
you know,
I don't have any religious beliefs.
You might say that to yourself.
It's like,
fine,
why do you watch Disney movies?
What the hell do you think you're doing
in the theater?
You don't think that's a religious
experience.
It's just cause you're completely
clueless about what religious
experiences are.
You're watching a bunch of pictures,
like their drawings,
you know,
there are things that aren't even real.
And then you're just in there like
embedded in there.
It's got your imagination.
So you say,
well,
I don't believe in any of that.
So like,
yeah,
right.
So come on,
you believe in it
basically.
Yes,
but it's,
it's,
uh,
there's a problem underneath that that's
even a bit deeper because like,
I think the dominance hierarchies real
period real,
but it's not,
it's,
it's a weird structure cause it's,
it's like,
you know,
it's like the example I gave earlier
where there's the tunnel and the train
going through it and the train keeps at
any moment the train cars are full of
different things with dominant Turkey is
kind of like that.
It's actually a dissipative structure
that's tell you.
So a dissipative structure is like a,
uh,
you know,
when you let the water go out of a drain
and you get that coil,
that funnel.
Well,
is that a thing?
it's a constant across a series of
transformations.
It's a dissipative structure and the
physicist Schrodinger regarded people as
dissipative structures.
So because we're our,
our,
our structure isn't constant.
Like,
I don't know,
you've probably replaced every cell in
your body,
roughly speaking,
or at least the constituent elements of
air resell,
you know,
two or three times since you've been
alive.
But there you are.
So you're like this thing that's a
permanent structure in a flux and the
doormen hierarchy sport sort of like
that because the constituent elements of
it keep changing,
but it's,
existence is,
its existence is there.
And so I don't exactly know what to make
of a category like that,
except that I'm certainly going to say
that it's real.
Or if you don't like that,
I can say I don't care if it's real
because all of you act as if there's
nothing that's more real than that.
So that'll do for me,
because you know,
that brings up another question.
How do you know what someone regards is
real?
And one answer is while you listen to
what they say,
it's like,
uh,
no.
You watch what they do.
That's a much more accurate guide to who
they are because what do they know about
who they are?
They got a vague model of who they are
and it's usually hyper tilted towards
banality and conformity and self
protection and deceit and all sorts of
things.
Hurricane,
well [inaudible] like a hurricane is a
dissipative structures.
So that,
you know,
that's a reasonable analogy and the
spirit is often likened to the wind.
So,
so any other questions?
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's an appalling ideology because the
people who created it had the idea about
what it should be before they made it.
So it's propaganda.
You can say exactly what frozen is
about.
So it's propaganda.
A truly mythologically based story,
you can never fully say what it's about.
You can just talk about it forever and
ever and ever and ever.
So it's,
it's a wellspring of meaning.
So,
oh sure.
They are.
Of course that's what they're doing.
Oh yeah,
it's calculated marketing.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
It was hyper politically correct.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And they didn't need men and you know,
God,
give me a break.
You know,
just because you need men doesn't mean
you have to like them.
Yeah.
So,
so I mean I've thought a lot about the
difference between propaganda and art.
So art is actually a process rather than
an end product.
And with any luck,
if you have a piece of art,
the process is embedded in the
byproduct.
And so it reflects the process when you
bring it into your house.
And so it's an active,
it's a,
it's a crystallized act of exploration
and the real artist doesn't know what
they're doing.
They don't know what they're doing.
They're exploring.
I can,
I can recommend a film.
There's a film made of Picasso Wooden
Boat in 1957 and it was a black and
white film and it was actually a film of
him making a painting and he painted it
on glass so you could see what he was
doing.
It's really quite fascinating because
you can see that he's playing,
he sketches it in and then he rubs it
out.
So then he's sketches it in again and he
rubs it out and he sketches over here
and it's like there's a real dynamism
about it.
He doesn't plan it out to begin with.
Not that there's necessarily anything
wrong with that as an artistic endeavor
too,
but,
but Gasa was trying to explore and
understand and you know,
I don't know what you know about cubism
but cubism,
it's a strange thing.
But what he was doing with his cubism
was to try to show you that you only see
things from one perspective,
but the things exist in multiple
perspectives.
So you know,
a cubist painting is your face this way
and your face this way at the same time.
And so you could say,
well is that a more accurate way of,
of representing a person that just a
standard portrait.
And Picasso would say,
well in some ways definitely because it
captures the transformative element
rather the static element.
And so someone who's a true artist
doesn't have a political message.
And it's funny cause my house is full of
ideological propaganda from the Soviet
Union.
It's just packed full of it.
And it's so interesting to watch these
artifacts because a lot of them were
there socialist realist,
although mostly they're impressionist.
Really,
it's so interesting to watch them
because in that painting themselves,
there's a war that you can perceive.
And the war is a lot of the people who
made these paintings were incredibly
talented,
really,
really skilled.
Cause the Russians kept their,
their formal academy's open so the
Russians can really paint impressionism.
It's remarkable.
But their talents were encapsulated
within this book,
mostly stellar in this ideology.
And so in each canvas there's this war
between the ideological message and the
artistic message.
And what's so cool is the farther we get
away from the Soviet Union,
the more the art wins.
Because in 300 years there isn't gonna
be a shred left of that ideology.
And all they'll will be left to the
paintings is the art.
So
part of the reason that people are so
attracted to art is because the artist
actually manifests identity with the
process of transformation.
And so that's why the artist is a
cultural hero.
That's also why every nihilist worth his
salt wants to be an artist.
Like who are you?
What are you gonna say?
I'm an ils.
It's no,
I'm an artist.
It's like,
no you're not,
but I can see why you want to be.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Just cause you're a failure.
It doesn't mean you're an artist.
Well I think it depends on who you are.
It's really interesting to me.
But I'm really interested in that,
you know,
and I'm also interested in the way that
etiologies coopt more fundamental
processes to two and harness their
energy as a,
as a rational and motivating force.
And so for me,
these pieces of art propaganda are
extremely interesting.
I mean,
it's very interesting to be surrounded
by them because I can see this war going
on all the time.
So it's very cool.
And there are twinning far as I can
tell.
So that's very interesting because they
were pure propaganda,
many of them when I bought them.
But it's getting farther and farther
away from the Soviet Union.
So the more architectural elements are
coming to the forefront.
So
I think it would depend on the skill of
the artist,
you know,
and some of these artists are incredibly
skilled.
So to the degree that there are,
there's genuine artistic merit in the
painting,
regardless of its constraint,
that can itself is value.
So,
Yep.
So any other questions?
Okay.
So while you basically know where we're
headed.
So I'm going to start telling you
stories in the next class,
a little more neural,
a little neuroscience,
and then a lot of stories.
So.